el sábado en las playas de río de
janeiro estuvieron casi tan llenas como
antes de la pandemia aunque esta ciudad
fue una de las más golpeadas por el cob
y 19 en brasil los días de sol han
llevado a los brasileños al mar el
viernes fue el día más caliente en río
desde febrero con 37.6 grados celsius y
además los habitantes de la ciudad dicen
que ya están exhaustos del encierro
y nadie puede soportar estar en casa por
más tiempo es difícil la pandemia ya
lleva más de seis meses y nadie puede
aguantar más
por ejemplo yo tuve el kobe y me mejoré
no tuve síntomas casi toda mi familia lo
tuvo se recuperaron nadie tuvo problemas
de todo así que ya no hay manera de
quedarse en casa
sao paulo también regresa poco a poco a
la normalidad el viernes en la noche
había tantos carros viajando desde la
capital hacia las playas que se
generaron estos embotellamientos el
estado concentra casi un cuarto de todos
los contagios del país y ya lleva cuatro
semanas consecutivas con una reducción
en el número de muertes su reapertura
gradual comenzó desde julio y ahora el
turno fue para el acuario de sao paulo
y nos instalamos cabinas de desinfección
en la entrada y también tenemos un
tapete para la desinfección a lo largo
del recorrido tenemos señales de
advertencia para establecer la distancia
mínima de un metro y medio entre los
visitantes a pesar de las buenas
noticias el gobernador de sao paulo joao
doria insiste en que no pueden bajar la
guardia y es que si bien los contagios
han disminuido levemente en brásil en
solo lo que va de esta semana se han
confirmado más de 260 mil casos en
comparación con los más de 300.000
diagnósticos positivos de la peor semana
de julio